This creepy Deli in New Jersey is hiding
a dark secret on the outside your
hometown Deli was barely scraping by
it's so less than 60 dollars worth of
food a day their Hoagies were all under
10 which meant they probably only had
around three to six customers a day and
the interior well it wasn't exactly fine
dining to say the least this place was
not exactly a thriving business but on
the inside the owners were using this
Deli for the most insane case of fraud
ever using fake accounts the owner sold
companies talk to each other over and
over again to pump the price of this
Deli stock to the moon and investors
fell for it what started out as a dollar
25 per share for this Deli skyrocketed
to over 13 a share making this place
earn the nickname of the infamous 100
million dollar Deli
and this is how they pull it off stay
dangerous click the Subscribe button and
let's get into it
[Music]
[Music]
do you like free stuff well you can get
up to 12 free stocks value up to 30 600
when you sign for Weeble with the link
below there's no catch all you have to
do is open an account deposit as little
as one dollar and that is it you'll get
up to 12 free stocks value up to 30 600
deposit it straight into your accounts
and yes once the stocks have settled in
your accounts you can sell them use that
money to buy other software even
withdraw the money so you might as well
pause the video and click the link below
to claim your free stocks now because
this promotion is definitely not gonna
last forever signing up is super fast
and easy all you have to do is fill out
some basic information deposit some
money and you're done the first two
shares you get when you open your
account will be valued up to 300 each
and the next four to ten shares you get
after you deposit some money in your
account will be valued up to three
thousand dollars each we are going into
a recession right now so you're gonna
wanna make sure you have everything set
up and ready to go so that you can buy
if and when everything crashes and
Weeble is the app to do it it's a really
great commission free stock trading app
that was ranked the best investment app
in 2021 by benzinga and it has a 4.5
star rating From Nerd while so what are
you waiting for get your 12 free stocks
value up to 30 600 right now by pausing
the video and clicking the link below
thanks to Weeble for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
so your dreams patent a New Jersey
native who has dreams of becoming the
next Wolf of Wall Street you've been
trying to make it big in the world of
High Finance since the 80s but the
problem is in 1998 you got caught
committing fraud and got banned from
being a stock broker whoops but fear not
there are ways around this for an
ambitious guy like yourself you're not
gonna let some silly court order stop
you from achieving your dreams you just
gotta make sure Regulators don't know
it's you behind the scenes pulling the
strings you've just gotta hide your name
from everything that is where the beauty
of shell companies comes in a company
that might look completely legit on
paper except it doesn't have any
employees offices any actual running
business and most importantly your name
is nowhere to be found on the records
all you gotta do is create a shell
company get it listed on the stock
market which we'll talk about later it's
easier than you think do some Financial
trickery to pump the stock price to the
Moon with the goal of making other
investors think hey this stock is
growing like crazy we gotta get in on
this and buy some shares and once that
happens you you simply dump the shares
on them and make off with tens of
millions of dollars so in 2015 you
finally registered your new business for
some reason you decided not to make some
futuristic looking tech company or even
a boring big business like trash
collecting no you decided to execute
your multi-million dollar plan based on
a deli but it's not just any Deli your
hometown Deli it became part of your
brand new shell company Hometown
International this Deli might have
looked more like a prison but after you
worked your magic it would be worth more
than your wildest dreams but as business
gurus always say for any successful
Venture you gotta build an All-Star team
foreign
[Music]
first off you put your man Paul Marina
down as the company's CEO CFO Treasurer
director and you make him the largest
shareholder who is this Maverick that is
able to handle so many vital roles in
the company why a renowned wrestling
coach and principal for the high school
next to the deli of course Paulsboro
High School is a literal 10-minute walk
from the deli so our guy Paul doesn't
have to worry about a long commute
convenient right next up we've got
Christine lindenmuth you put her as the
vice president and Secretary of the
company what are her credentials you may
ask she's a 46 year old math teacher and
administrator at that same High School
our wrestling coach works at and you
thought we were lying when we said
All-Star team but let's be honest these
are not the type of people to commit
Securities fraud luckily you know
someone who does a guy by the name of
Peter Coker senior Peter had been sued
by American Express for nine hundred
thousand dollars of unpaid debts which
he tried to escape by declaring
fraudulent bankruptcy he had to settle a
lawsuit with a furniture store for
trying to embezzle a million dollars
while he was vice president and way back
in 1992 he got arrested for trying to
solicit prostitution from a group of
girls as young as 10 years old but most
importantly he had exactly what you
needed his own set of shell companies
and a foolproof plan needless to say
Peter Coker senior was the exact guy for
the job now all you needed was to list
your Deli on the stock market and you'd
be golden but let's be honest there's no
way that a company that owns one Deli
that has been in business for less than
a year was gonna be allowed on a big
Stock Exchange like the NASDAQ or New
York Stock Exchange the regulations and
scrutiny are crazy these places are
carefully monitored all transactions are
tracked and the minute they catch
someone breaking the rules they can just
delist the company Hometown
International wouldn't last five minutes
there but fear not because there are
other places you can list your company
to offer a little bit more leniency some
more people didn't mind taking a gamble
on an All or Nothing company promising
them millions and that somewhere is
called the over-the-counter or OTC
markets
[Music]
first you want to file your paperwork
with the SEC and tell them that this is
quote a new Delicatessen concept which
sells home style sandwiches food items
and groceries in a casual and friendly
atmosphere
there we go now that sounds like a hip
Innovative company people would want to
throw money at you list the wrestling
coach and math teacher as the primary
shareholder so your name is off their
radar
then you can get your company listed on
the over-the-counter Market unlike big
centralized stock exchanges where you
can instantly buy and sell stocks from
Big vetted companies like apple or
Amazon whenever you want on your phone
because your trades are routed to a
centralized exchange that facilitates
the trade for you like the weibo stock
trading app that gives you up to 12 free
stocks valued up to thirty thousand six
hundred dollars when you sign up for
Weeble with the link below and make a
deposit
the OTC market is a very different Beast
it's a completely decentralized system
where buyers and sellers trade stock
with one another directly there's no
Central organization overseeing the
trade if you're the seller you're
dealing with the buyer directly this
gives the OTC market some advantages
unlike the big exchanges you don't get
automatically kicked out for being
sketchy the only thing the OTC market
can do if they suspect something shady
is going on is flag the company for
suspicious behavior and report it to the
SEC if needed it's a place where both
honest companies and very sketchy ones
are free to do as they please which
leaves you with a lot of wiggle room
perfect now Hometown International
ticker symbol hwim is listed on the OTC
market now it's finally game time
this is where your All-Star Guy Peter
Coker Senior comes in you remember the
guy that tried to diddle little girls we
do not little kids Coker senior already
had a shell company on the OTC market
E-Waste as well as a fake investment
firm called Tryon Capital so you two get
together and start pumping this Deli to
the Moon here's how it works on a
regular Stock Exchange like the one you
use on your phone stock prices are set
automatically based on supply and demand
how many people are buying and selling
and since there are a ton of legitimate
people buying and selling Apple for
example at any given time you get a
pretty accurate price of what the stock
should be at but in the OTC markets
there's a lot less transactions going on
if a company has no one trading its
shares whatever the next one transaction
is will set the price of the stock you
can charge as high a price for your
stock as you want as long as you find
someone willing to pay it anytime
someone trades more than 100 shares this
gets printed or registered in the market
state
and then boom that's the new price for
this stock and that's where Coker
seniors other shell companies came into
play see you and Coker would sell just
enough shares of Hometown International
to his other shell companies to
gradually raise the stock price to make
the stock look enticing but without
raising any eyebrows but Coker isn't
just gonna buy your shares and pump your
company for free so your shell company
pays his shell companies Consulting fees
like administrative and other
miscellaneous services or support in the
research development and Analysis of
product financial and strategic matters
because you know building a new
Delicatessen concept which sells home
style sandwiches food items and
groceries in a casual and friendly
atmosphere takes a lot of outside help
this made Hometown International looked
like it was a legitimate company doing
legitimate business dealings but again
you don't want to pump the stock too
fast no you want the stock to increase
just enough over a good amount of time
so that other investors think to
themselves man this stock has a great
track record of consistently going up
this must be a really Innovative
restaurant concept I should buy some
shares for myself
unfortunately that was easier said than
done and after a couple of years nobody
else seemed to really be taking the bait
but that didn't get you down you weren't
the type to give up so easily all you
needed was a new plan and luckily Peter
Coker senior had a son in Hong Kong who
knew just how to turn your idea around
[Music]
Peter Coker Jr is a classic example of
the Apple not falling far from the tree
but unlike his father he took the
business of Investments internationally
see he specializes in what's called
reverse mergers and it would be your
ticket to riches basically in a reverse
merger a private company can merge with
a company that's already gone public the
companies merged together and all of a
sudden the private company gets all the
money they would get by going public
themselves without all the red tape and
scrutiny of going through the IPO
process and the great thing is that
there are a ton of Chinese companies
looking to go public in the U.S through
reverse mergers because that kind of
exposure to the American Stock Market
can make them an obscene amount of money
therefore they're willing to pay
American companies a lot of money to do
a reverse merger with them that is where
Hometown International comes in
the perfect shell company listed on the
OTC markets with nothing actually going
on that a Chinese firm can merge with
Coker Jr had been working this kind of
hustle in Hong Kong since the mid-2000s
so he got right to work he got a few
Hong Kong and Macau based firms to
invest a few million into Hometown
International and together they set out
a convoluted plan to get this reverse
merger in action everything was going
according to plan but before the merger
would go through you got greedy and
decided to get even more money while the
shell company was still yours you were
going to squeeze it for all it was worth
before handing it off to someone else
all of you started trading the stock
back and forth with each other like
crazy from 2019 to 2021 the deli went
from one dollar and 25 cents a share to
13 a share more than 10 times their
original value multiply that 13 share
price by the number of shares that were
out there and you got a deli that was
worth over a hundred in dollars now you
could sell all your shares at a
ridiculous profit then make even more
money with the merger and with that all
evidence of your shell company would be
buried but before the deal went through
people noticed your stock skyrocketing
and you caught the attention of someone
you really shouldn't have
David Einhorn is the founder and
president of a hedge fund called green
light capital
he's worth more than 1.4 billion dollars
making him one of the apex predators of
Wall Street he also has a reputation for
being a whistleblower when he spots
something he thinks might be a fraud so
when he noticed Hometown International
Incorporated climbing fast on the OTC
market of course he had to see what was
going on in a letter to investors he
made a joke about the deli and how the
whole thing was kind of suspect saying
the pastrami must be amazing
and when someone posted that letter on
Twitter it caused an uproar why is this
Deli worth 100 million dollars if it
only makes sixteen thousand dollars a
year why was there this Deli that had 77
percent of its shares owned by Hong Kong
and Macau firms
why is the CEO also the local wrestling
coach and why is it Delhi paying
thousands in consultant fees for fast
food experience to try on Capital who
has no listed experience in fast food
but does list things like medical real
estate golf supplies and an insurance
program for trees this caught the
attention of the media reporters started
calling the deli constantly or even
visiting it to find out if it sold real
food and with that your cover was blown
the OTC market responded by demoting
Hometown International hand slapping a
buyer's beware warning next to your name
a literal skull and crossbones symbol
this was bad you'd have to move fast to
escape before the SEC came after you so
you fired the wrestling coach and math
teacher in an attempt to save face you
killed the Consulting deals with Coker
shell companies and in a desperate
scramble to push a reverse merger
through you tried to team up with a
bioplastics company from California but
none of that could save you eventually
the SEC did come after you and accused
you of stock fraud wire fraud and money
laundering now you Peter Coker senior
and Peter Coker Jr face up to 20 years
in prison if convicted lucky for junior
he's still somewhere in Hong Kong so who
knows if they'll ever catch him but at
least the Philly cheesesteak was good
[Music]
sadly for James Patton and the cokers
they could never convince the public
that their stocks were in high demand
but you know what product is always in
demand vaccines think about it there's
always a new disease popping up throwing
the public into mass panic and with each
new disease people frantically demand a
cure or some way to prevent them from
getting sick in the first place which
gives you the perfect opportunity to
profit see the government and vaccine
makers have a symbiotic relationship but
obviously this is stuff that's way too
spicy to be released publicly without
getting demonetized so we cover it all
in our latest documentary The profitable
business of vaccines and you can watch
it right now by scrolling down and
clicking that join button below once you
join you'll get instant access to this
documentary along with a new one every
month that is too controversial to be
released publicly these are the topics
that we have always wanted to cover but
have never been able to because they
would get demonetized and not promoted
as much by the algorithm topics like
everyone's favorite Private Island owner
every jepstein the roots of Middle
Eastern Terror the cia's torture program
and much more and there's a refund
policy too unlike most YouTube
memberships so if you join in you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining for the first
time and we will personally refund you
for your first month after your first
month there is no refund so scroll down
and click that join button now
I don't know about you guys but I for
one found this case super super
hilarious so let me know what you
thought in the comments below and if
you're new here this is one of the
biggest channels on YouTube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime just like this video so you can
learn how the world really works instead
of becoming a victim to it so if you
like that philosophy if you want to be
more dangerous click that subscribe
button below you follow me on Instagram
for more day in the life kind of stuff
but that's gonna wrap it up thank you so
much for being part of the watch the end
Club stay dangerous out there and I will
see you guys in the next one
thank you
[Music]